yep welcome to against what BuzzFeed
pink tail today we are going to be
eating a bunch of Pokemon themed Donuts
made by donut time which is this kleiner
hipster donut shop at started in
Brisbane my hometown they do like weird
combinations and to celebrate the
popularity of both my go they've done
pokeball donuts which I hope I call
Pokemon go nuts oh is it Pokemon going
on it's not oh I choose you pikachu or
something I hate that I'm an occasional
fan of donuts I don't only have a sweet
tooth I like salt I don't think I'm
gonna enjoy this up being said though I
love Nutella and they seem to be
overflowing with round sludge I think I
probably have the biggest sweet tooth on
the team I eat a lot of junk oh oh geez
I can't wait to eat on camera it's right
up there with eating on baby okay
they're all marked they're all missing
just like bits like they've been through
the wars like I went when I bought them
she was just know there's really heavy
like the bumps a little bit soggy which
is kind of disgusting it's very gooey
it's got like paper for this bit for the
middle part of the pokeball I don't know
if that's edible or not i assume is
edible I hope it's edible cuz I'm gonna
eat it it's really cool yeah what's also
discussing is the hole at the back where
they filled ah the the pokeball with
chocolate I want to tell her I think it
is but it just looks incorrect like I
don't know if that's accurate two
pokéballs like if a Pokemon goes into a
poker ball it's turned into some kind of
brown liquid until it's then
reconstituted out of the ball but dive
in haha influential camera at least one
so I break it over like a regular poker
oh god no I was a mistake it's so
doorway to darna days I can turn up this
is way more intense on a krispy kreme I
would say don't salty why is it salty
from him so I could appreciate the red
oh no oh that's really sweet that's
really soon I can already feel my heart
right like rising oh man it's just the
doughnut dough itself is really doing
then at ellerslie sticky and the glaze
is just all over the place I also feel
like it's just going to be stored in
this ridiculous mustache for the rest of
time I'm gonna try this paper bit this
is we're gonna hit the pokemon with to
actually catch it because it opens a
pokeball tastes like paintball I mean
it's paper that I used to love when I
was little going to kids birthday
parties when they have paper on the
cupcakes oh I thought it was so cool but
it was only other girls birthdays boys
never had an equivalent like we never
had para cupcakes with like skull and
crossbones was always fairies all right
it's kind of tastes like though it will
save myself now I'm gonna get a little
bit so i'ma tella cuz i'm on australia
oh my god there's so much what a lot
that's too much Nutella that's great oh
I'm gonna eat it now that's great just
like pokemon it's just like my dad cuz
we're gonna eat them all I give it 4
pokeballs at a time so I can't see
myself eating one of these ever again I
want to leave the table I don't want to
spoil my parents it's good i mean it's
nice tastes like a blazer no I just
personally I'm not that big fun filled
donut I rate this original 150 out of
the existing number of pokemon but I
don't know what that number is now I
assume it's in thousands you've got to
set a keys and a pile of garbage so it's
not rating Oh